the jurgen experience you didn't bring
marshall i wanted to meet the dog
yeah unfortunately i'm going to go shoot
guns after this i'm going next week
yeah where you going i think angelus
forest oh okay
yeah i know where that is just the
outdoor yeah there's great range out
there yeah my friend tokes has a bunch
of guns
have you done it before i went with him
once before
and i cried the first time cried the
first time you pulled the trigger
in ecstasy uh no yeah fear
because i was just like it was just so
scary it's such a powerful feeling
and it really freaked me out and then i
started to have fun and i was like
wow yeah got into it you went the other
way yeah but it was like one of those
things where i'm like
i'd be fine if i never did like i wasn't
like i have to keep doing this but
if the opportunity presents itself so it
didn't become an obsession but you
and you were entertained yeah there were
certain guns that i liked shooting more
than
others that were more fun it's a smart
thing to learn how to do
yeah unfortunately when you see the
santa monica scene
you see the thin veneer of civilization
pulled off and how
easily people can go crazy it's a bummer
but it's real
yeah yeah
i just hope it all gets better me too i
feel like everyone's so negative
are you uh eagerly anticipating what's
gonna happen during the election
are you weirded out by like the
possibility that no matter who wins it
could be chaos
uh yeah i think like what you were
saying it's like it's already
you know we already kind of see through
the government and realize it's all
pretty [ __ ] regardless of whoever wins
no matter how good the candidate is but
i also think that this has shown us
like we do have so much power to
influence what happens it's
not so much who the figure is or the
person wearing the suit it's more about
like people coming together
and like making some change themselves
you sound like a person who bought in
all the political propaganda that
they're pumping out in the news right
now
this it's really about big businesses
and special interests
making as much money as possible and
keeping people fat and stupid
and they do their best to keep us
uneducated trapped inside our house with
low vitamin d
and then they create viruses and then
they release those viruses
no i don't think that i know i know i
know but only [ __ ] around if you
didn't get it
people at home yeah i don't know i just
i think that we
do i think we're just realizing that we
do have more power to influence how
things go
sure we do yeah we we have more of a
voice for sure than ever before
it's it's it's very interesting i just
want people
hopefully to use their voice in like a
positive way i think that it's really
easy to like attack people
regardless of whether it's political or
not nowadays with anything going on it's
so easy to be like a negative voice
when i think well it feels you feel
angry
you know the anger that most people have
is uh accentuated by
the economic situation and the virus
situation right so
even if you are already like a angry
person
you're going to be really angry now and
frustrated and it doesn't seem like a
way out
i almost like the way people are the we
way people are behaving today
with all the tension and all the
infighting and all the chaos
it's almost like this isn't
it's not even their fault i i really
almost feel that way i feel like
most people are so unprepared for
something this stressful and anything
that's really stressful like that gets
you so out of your head
and when everybody's out of their head
and no one can just calm down
it's not a good combination it's not
good for anybody and
the real problem is there's not a real
clear
antidote for it yeah there's not a real
clear path out of this that's what makes
me real nervous
that's why i know it sounds so
miscongeniality but i think like if
people were just like nicer to each
other
yeah it sounds so corny but not all the
time it doesn't need to be like
phony niceness but rather than being
like mean or negative or attacking just
don't
say i mean i don't know i just
people have requirements and one of the
requirements is they have to be able to
make a living
yeah you know and i as much as i think
that uh
universal basic income like one of the
things is this whole
pandemic [ __ ] it's shown us that it's
not a bad idea to have a certain amount
of money that you have allocated to
everybody so that they could pay their
bills and pay for food it seems
like we should figure that out and
andrew yang was talking about this
in terms of automation but it's just as
important with or more important with
this
yeah with the pandemic because you don't
have any choices everybody has i mean
it's like
if automation comes and takes your job
maybe you can figure out another job
yeah but if there's no [ __ ] jobs
because no one's allowed to work
then that's the best argument ever for
universal basic income
because yeah i can't do anything it's
not your fault yeah
i feel like only fans is like the new
trading of furs
it's like here's nudes can i make money
do you that is such a great joke
you shouldn't have said that on the
podcast you just saved that one okay i'm
putting it in the bank
yeah we have to [ __ ] delete that no
keep it in it's funny
it's very funny people yeah it's very
funny i need any funny moment
leave it the way it is and then uh just
expand upon it as a bit because
you're totally right it is like the new
training because i was thinking i'm like
okay well if comedy's dead and there's
like i can either sell chicken wings but
like
i don't know there's only so many i want
to go back to trading but there's only
so much you can trade and like the only
thing i have is my feet
during time
[Applause]
you